نتابع واياكم هذه الصور المباشره من باريس
لاستمرار المظاهرات التي بدات منذ هذا
الصباح وتطورت طبعا لمواجهات بين
المتظاهرين والقوى الامنيه في مدينه
فرنسيه في باريس وفي عدد من المناطق
الفرنسيه الاحصاءات الاوليه تشير الى ان
اكثر من نصف مليون فرنسي نزلوا الى الشارع
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما طبعا هو الموضوع الذي يعتبر
محل رفض واسع في الشارع الفرنسي لما له
تداعيات على يعني سن التقاعد وعلى مخصصات
التقاعد وعلى امور اخرى طبعا
هناك
مطالبات للحكومه الفرنسيه وللرئيس الفرنسي
وللرئاسه بالتراجع عن هذا القانون او ايضا
كان هناك مطالبات باسقاط الحكومه هذه
التظاهرات ما زالت مستمره وهي
التظاهره العاشره على الت منذ ان تم اقرار
هذا القانون الذي كما هو معلوم اقر طبعا
بدون العوده الى الجمعيه العموميه نظرا
للماده الدستوريه التي اعتمدت والتي جرى
عبرها تمديد هذا القانون ساشير مشاهدينا
هذا العاجل الذي ورد عن فرنسيه بان اعمال
نهب للمحلات التجاريه وحرائق في باريس
خلال الاحتجاجات على قانون التقاعد ما
زالت يعني هي
تجرى وتجرى بهذه الاسماء طبعا اعمال النهب
واعمال التكسير والتخريب دائما ما نشهدها
خلال التظاهرات الفرنسيه ان كان ايام
الجيليجون وان كان منذ بدء هذه التظاهرات
عاده عندما يعني تكون هناك اعداد كبيره
ويكون هناك مواجهات وعنف يكون هناك اعمال
شغب وتكسير واعمال نهب اذا التظاهره
مازالت مستمره هدات نوعا ما المواجهات بين
القوى الامنيه بين الشرطه الفرنسيه وبين
المتظاهرين الذين يعني منذ ايام عمدوا الى
احراق سيارات احراق
النفايات وطبعا يعني الدرام النيران بعدد
من المحلات
وجدات الفرنسيه